so for the past couple of decades the
nation of sweden the small scandinavian
country has taken in more refugees per
capita than any place on earth
in 2015 sweden got more than 160
000 asylum applications mainly from
syria iraq and afghanistan
that accounts for nearly two percent of
sweden's entire population so what's the
effect of this bin
eva flaredingerbrook is a legal
philosopher who's from sweden and we're
happy to have her on for the first time
tonight eva thanks so much for coming on
so we don't often enough get to the
result
so we know what sweden did what happened
next
well what happened next was a
skyrocketing crime
epidemic i would almost say i mean just
a week ago we had a new report come out
about lethal gun violence in sweden
and it turns out that sweden has gone
from one of the safest countries in
europe
to now the second most dangerous country
in europe when it comes to lethal gun
violence
in just a time period of 10 years so
the effects of mass migration and
demographic change haven't been small
to say the least and still many people
refuse to make this link
but i would have to say that anybody who
at this point still refuses to make the
link between migration
and the rise that we're seeing in crime
in sweden either lives in an ivory tower
or has an interest in trying to cover up
the truth because we're not just talking
about lethal gun violence here i mean
we're talking about
gang wars that are being fought out in
the streets of sweden
uh explosions knife crime and not to say
at least
soaring numbers of rapes as well so um
yeah like i said the effect the effects
aren't small at all
but there are people who are very much
willing to cover this up
because obviously the social democratic
government in sweden
who is responsible for these detrimental
effects
would clearly prefer to have the swedish
people
not to know what the exact numbers are
about and the link between crime and
migration
so what they'll do is they'll say for
example with this report about lethal
gun violence
they won't even mention the word
migration they won't even mention
cultural clashes uh or um
incompatibilities they'll just say oh
you know what these people the
perpetrators that are committing these
crimes they come from socially
disadvantaged areas
so basically prime example of this
neo-marxist rhetoric
that the government is pushing that the
media is pushing in order to cover up
the truth
so sweden goes from one of the safest
places in the world to the second most
dangerous country in europe after
kosovo and the people who run the
country
pretend it's not happening so i guess
they don't care about the people who
live in sweden
well i mean that's the only conclusion
that you can take from this they care
more about being in power
clearly so that's exactly what's
happening this neo-marxist rhetoric
basically
in sweden you can steal kill rape and
still
if you're a migrant you can be the
victim in all this
and the effects are terrible for people
who are living in sweden
um and yeah without if the people of
sweden don't
break through this politically correct
climate this
suffocating politically correct climate
and they don't start
calling a spade a spade then i'm afraid
that nothing much
will change at all so that's basically
the first step that sweden needs to
start taking now and that's making the
right diagnosis i mean
you can't change what you don't
acknowledge so as long as people are too
afraid to say
this obviously does have something to do
with immigration
sweden never used to have gang wars up
until well this decade
for example then um how how is anything
ever
ever going to change and that i mean
without that
they won't get to the second step which
is obviously that sweden
needs a migration stop from people
coming from these
radically different cultures
so yeah that's sweden is so far behind
in this debate that i'm very worried
that if we don't
um if we don't turn this around now then
things will look really really bad for
sweden and europe as a whole
yeah but they'll let you die before they
admit it ava thanks so much for coming
on i hope we see you again
thank you hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else